[Musique]
nous ne savons pas pourquoi nous sommes
là
nous ne savons pas qui a bâti le silo
ni pourquoi nous sommes sous terre
nous savons seulement que dans le monde
à l'extérieur de notre sanctuaire règne
la mort
si on devait réduire le pacte à une
seule règle ce serait
le titre surtout pas que vous voulez
sortir
ou vous sortirez de merde vous
sortirez
ça t'arrive jamais de penser au monde
au-delà du silo peut-être que ce qu'on
voit ici ce n'est pas ce qu'il y a en
surface
aux machines
tout le monde a toujours une théorie sur
le silo
je dois découvrir la vérité
je crois que les réponses à de
nombreuses questions sont sur ce
vous devez rester tranquille
et vous faire la plus discret possible
êtes-vous prêt à vous dévouer corps et
âme pour servir le silo
[Musique]
nous n'avons plus beaucoup de
de thé du menaces grave à l'ordre du
silo moi je m'en fous complètement ce
que je veux c'est trouver la vérité
[Musique]
parfois il vaut mieux que certains
mystères ne soient pas résolus